meu muito a partir de sexta que as
coisas 7 11 dominou o pessoal está bem
que eu sou é do sul mestre do deus um
mestre do equilibrismo além de conseguir
equilibrar tudo o que mais um vídeo do
microscópio mas já é passado na vida
pessoal
quero agradecer muito mesmo muito porque
não tem vídeo nos carros 5 milhões de
dilma tem uma meta de 500 mil likes
porque uma mensagem vai continuar né a
minha namorada vai escolher vai ter um
solo de 12 nós vamos ver fruta no
microscópio já tem um pouco ontem um
gogo tem um mel limão mamão laranja e na
china eu adoro e na sobra de chute não
saiu porque muitas vezes a fruta tem
coisas lá com eles não apenas por bichos
minhocas larvas eu lembro uma vez o
comer uma maçã que ela estava impecável
por fora que muito linda mas a arma
entrou olha só isso uma mão do play-off
embora só vá já está em tratamento e
vamos tentar atingir uma meta do chá em
lei que instituiu o sistema online
eu vou tentar comer um pouquinho ainda
assim em poder da polícia pode fazer a
um confronto a 50 idéias podem dizer
isso a nossa primeira fruta vai ter um
pouco à parte fora do corpo de pessoas
risos essa coisa aqui tem uma textura
muito ruim
mesmo é de um pêlo eo atual 32 vai com o
microscópio
olha esse apelo em um bom estado a
participar é uma terra sei lá eu vou
tentar ver uma partida assim marcou essa
parte de uma lei com base em um buraco é
bem diferente do resto e texturas ao teu
lado pessoal não sabia o que vou tentar
mais um vídeo mil litros um só entrar
dentro do country em um buraco mas eu
tenho certeza absoluta que lhe permitiu
encontrar uma larga em alguma fruta que
eu sei o que muito encontrar um bicho em
uma lagoa no monte com um espírito aqui
cuida meu banho lucro só não eu vou ter
que pedir desculpa não é muito duro bom
vai passar à próxima fase o pessoal que
vai ser então uma fruta muito comum que
todos nós comemos que é a laranja é e
como você já sabe a laranja é uma enorme
fonte de receita é de apenas meio que o
player é muito grande 321 mais laranja
olha aí
uau já está focada e tudo é bailer anj
tem algumas pintas pretas questão que
compilou sua kombi lo pelo quer
conquistar o mundo até na fruta mel pela
obra já está em todo o lado até pelo
nosso cabelo laranja não não não
em outro um pelo outro não é muito tempo
aqui só para te ver a textura por dentro
agora eu já tenho que me atacou
profissional dos samurais de indígenas
não brincam para enfrentar o sol é
perigoso eu estou a brincar posso porque
o suspense winstanley
uma manobra vamos cuidar agora vai ser
muito sumo olha só para anjo você olha
pensa presos comer não é muito gostoso
olha isso bem suculenta lenk do ensino
prestado com medo portanto fazer um sumo
de laranja em 2012 disse o sérvio
o cristo é bem mais curta que o estranho
um fruta tropical olha só dois têm muita
mão e textura windows muita coisa preta
dentro da fruta ou pelo outro pelo
dentro de uma mão só
- querem conquistar a terra mas voltámos
mães quanto que tente entrar na terra e
por sua vez conquistaram os humanos
ok só vou ficar com as mãos todos por
500 e coladas portanto vamos ter outra
fruta próximo de nós vamos ver se vai
ser então um e vi o que eu e vejam só
estuda desfruto maravilhosa sempre como
que virou está muito muito ácido e que
fazem os dois aqui ou então ela é muito
doce muito bom eu estava indo portanto
eu acho que está sim mas vamos ver a
textura hora e isso tem muito pelos
investimentos tanto assim
envolvido agora ocupando queria leiga
igual muito poluído ok só vamos lá então
agora abrir o que viverá textura por
dentro e também deve ser muito lindo
olha só meu é muito lindo que vinham
muito embora lá pessoal 3211 mais em
olha só a parte verde tem um bloco que
não teve
eu não sei se aqui em um contexto de
frutose o açúcar da fruta mas tem muitas
pedras e lúcio canela meu é muito bom
só vou tentar mas primeiro um pouco e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer com um
microscópio 321 vai usar dois primeiros
[Música]
segmentos dentro dela tem vários
instrumentos dentro da cimentos bem
estranho não só ao próximo
então o nosso amigo 321 vai assim tem
muita textura outro pela folha
observando pelo tá tudo sujo
olha me orgulha muito por lei é
continuamente pela homenagem estranho
isso é coisa que eu encontrei com o mais
pequeno do mundo tem muito muito nem da
presidência nem dá pra ver nada numa
onda destruidora mas por dentro não é
assim tão interessante né mas por fora é
muito lindo mesmo que eu tenho que mais
morango eu também adoro grande porque o
som tem muito dono de banco lembra eu
vou ficar aqui o maior no mundo todo
olha só o gigante bora lá só a morango
em 3 2 1 mas fui muito com várias cores
até aqui o movimento assim amarela aqui
outro lá em cima e vermelha ganho louco
bicho que só um morango deste tipo 1500
ac tem muitas mente que coisas mais
clean patas do inseto olha aí a folha
deu bem ver o que tem textura da
domótica dominó
mesmo que isso eu ia comer frango é
muito pequeno inseto na mulher com qual
o bicho é esse meu explica bicho aí é só
meu é muito assustador
ao todo o documento não foi muito pelo
cérebro
outros acharam lista que o inseto é isso
cometem se vocês souberem contou nunca
vi algo assim e aí posso falar como se
aplique com o estúdio já sabem que não
vou falar vocês vão ter dois filhos que
provavelmente não virão aqui embaixo
vocês podem se inscrever aqui no canal
usar e já sabem como também coisas
ficaram que eu vejo microscópios querem
passar frutas parte 2 não sair só fiquem
idéia é aproximar